when i was asked to
nc i've never done this before and i
actually as i mentioned before never
been to css conf before
or a css conference um so i was really
excited to come and
and i was trying to think like well how
would i end
such a great like group of speakers and
and i don't know i just i feel really
inspired and
i was going to talk about like my wish
list for like what i want
in the future is css but i realize i
feel like we've
tapped out css as a language i think
we've
done it all and i my background
started in academia and then i worked
in sports media tech at the nba and
a couple of the the main thing i learned
from working in those industries
is how to monetize things so i figure
like
instead of talking about like what i
want for css
i would give you some of my ideas on how
maybe we should monetize
css so that's what i'm gonna
talk about and so i have a i have a
couple ideas bear with me they might
sound a little crazy but like i was
going over my slides before and now i'm
starting to think like you know what i
think i've got like a good couple of
ideas rolling
and what better place than css conf
where we have all these great minds here
that work at really cool places that can
make decisions
um and make these things happen and who
here
would think it's a cool idea if we all
made more money
yeah so
important is the first thing i want to
talk about
originally my wish list for css was to
get rid of important
important causes me a lot of stress and
it probably does for you
especially when you pull in third-party
libraries that have css
files and they used important on all of
them and you know it's a pain in the
butt
but like instead of getting rid of it
like we could just make it harder for
people to use
by monetizing it uh
like and so like how can we monetize
importance like what is
importance it's like some weird like
social construct that we can totally
take advantage of
so i said i propose that we introduce
some politics and bureaucracy
into important um so like we can create
the sort of like government
of css politicians who pass laws on what
can be important and what cannot be
important
um and i put democracy in scare quotes
because really like we
don't know how to do that sort of stuff
but like some people
might say like oh well we had the w3c
like we could handle it but like i feel
like they're a little distracted right
now so maybe like we can just do like a
total coup
and take over ourselves and create
another group
we all know like the more groups you
have deciding the same thing
obviously is like the best approach so
figure we should contribute to that
and like in terms of bureaucracy and
these are all things that i learned
working at montclair state in the nba
like in order to like make it difficult
to do something we have to like make
people apply for it or put it behind a
pay wall or
we can create these loose rules and a
never-ending debate
between our cool little democracy and
bury people and paperwork
before they're able to use um important
in their code and of course like
the great thing about politics is that
it always means more jobs and more money
um
not necessarily distributed to us
developers but the people in power
because when you have power you get
money when you have money and power you
have respect and this is something
little kim's been telling me since 1998
so obviously something we should look
into
z index this is my favorite css property
um because i love like math and and the
z plane and all that cool stuff but we
can totally
monetize the z index
the more money that you pay the more
stacks you can have
i mean my default for z index is like
99999 up until like
even beyond what a computer can
technically handle with the 32-bit
integers
um so like if we charge people for how
high their z index goes
well if you have a lot of layers you
know you're gonna have to pay more so
and i mean i don't know exactly who
they're gonna pay like us
whoever we are but i figured that's a
good idea
that's that's all the money that we're
going to be making
if we do this my favorite subject ever
seo right yeah
how can we monetize with seo well like
seo just automatically
means money um anyway um so like i have
this
i actually wrote some code i hope you
can see
and like it doesn't really like to the
when you're viewing in the browser
doesn't actually really do anything like
this code is useless
but if we can incorporate like search
optimization and bots and stuff so like
paul like see me later we can discuss
how google wants to work this into their
uh
road map but like why don't we just like
class name stuff everything and then
like everyone will definitely go
to my site that's styled by the css and
like you can inject
like your name and like all this sort of
stuff into css you put into client
projects and then
you get more clicks and then the
internet gives you more money because
that's like
where this money's coming from the
internet
javascript and css
so like i'm a javascript developer
and like we all know that like css
really don't need css as a language we
can do everything in css and javascript
so
i mean let's just get that out there
performance and all that
other stuff like aside like you know
javascript can do it
but like let's turn the tables on
javascript developers
like let's create a syntax in css where
we can put javascript
into the page
so like i mean i i've
come from a background in php
development so like
why don't we use like php to parse this
and inject it it just seems like it's
totally easy and
not tasking at all so we can do that and
make money through css that has
javascript in it
so like how would we do that well let's
rebrand it
um people whenever you like you work in
a company that markets things and like
this happens at sports teams all the
time they're like oh you know ticket
sales aren't so good like what should we
do like oh let's
change the name of the team and that
will like totally like blow it up and it
usually works that way so like
let's rename css with javascript syntax
inside of it and call it script
we can have like t-shirts and like
framework wars because
all the money that i make off of web
development is actually from arguing
about code on twitter so like we all can
get involved in
with this rebranding
i mentioned uh in the beginning of the
conference that css is a line language
because
you know what you see on the document
you end up looking at your page in the
browser
and it turns out it's just full of lies
so i feel like if we want to be taken
more seriously as css developers and
therefore make more
money we need to sort of stop being um
big fat liars all the time um and i i
tweeted this
a couple of days ago i was actually
really stressed out i was working on a
project
where we were sorting a column and
there's css triangles
pointing up when you started ascending
it would change down and i'm struggling
with that and then i was like thinking
like
why are we calling these triangles like
they're not triangles like if you take a
look at this code it's only
hiding parts of this box
you know so like i'm standing behind
this podium and you don't see my legs
you're not going to call me someone who
doesn't have
legs so like why are we lying about
triangles it drives me insane like this
is
that triangle in css and like why don't
we just use like
html which this is obviously more
semantic i take a look at ampersand
x25b2 and i'm like oh that's an upward
pointing solid triangle so
and it's like so much less code and you
know and yeah we might have to memorize
all these entities but
like what else are we going to do so
that's a little taste in my upcoming
talk at deprecate css conf where we just
get rid of all css
um so yeah in a nutshell
monetization is really easy we just
introduce politics
bureaucracy and just like basically not
use css at all
um also like again like let's stop
calling them triangles
and just like doing whatever i say
because i feel like anybody that's
listened to me
like usually gets it right along the way
so
i don't know and also like on a serious
note let's
just based on all the talks today like
keep the web pretty
funny accessible and experiment friendly
and i
i'm really happy to see based on what
everyone's been talking about today that
we're doing exactly that
with css so i wanted to keep it brief
because i know you want to party you've
heard me talk all day but
i wanted to thank you um i'm on twitter
it gets um that's a real email address
that's a real site um
and if you like don't want to read
serious stuff i do
write on medium all of like my jokey
satire thing so
and we're sponsored by soundgarden so
thank you for uh
thank you for bringing them in and
they're literally playing in new york
city a week from today i just learned
that
um i also don't really like sound garden
but don't let me know that
um but really um and just to take it
seriously which for me
it sounds funny i'm sure um i
want to say that seeing all the talks
today like there's like talks from
people who've never spoken before that
sounds so eloquent and
are doing such awesome stuff and i feel
really
uh honored to sort of be in the group
with all of you and i want to thank
nicole and all the organizers and chris
and
laura williams for organizing this
really awesome event
like i really needed this um
i really did so i want to thank you all
for
letting me make an ass out of myself all
day
i love to do it and i love to see all of
you
my new friends so thank you very much